greetings my friends and welcome to a
dummy Christmas review and now it's time
that we look at a Charlie Brown
Christmas Charlie Brown is a young boy
with some form of leukemia think about
that's why he's bald and depressed all
the time and he tries to discover the
true meaning of Christmas the answer he
figures must lie in his awkwardly
animated and awkwardly voice-acted
friends Linus I want to know what the
true meaning of Christmas is it's Jesus
okay and that's basically it the rest is
just filler why do people like it so
much well they didn't know what to think
of it as children and they still don't
know what to think of it now so
basically they feel that they don't like
it they don't get they don't want look
like they don't get it so they like it
but the music's awesome and I don't know
it's kind of hard not to like it you
know it's like when some of these kids
put together a little show but there's
really no plaid or climax or character
development but it's like kids you know
it's just join me and Charlie Brown is a
good Christmas special even if you can't
explain waiting but look at the bright
side it could have been done by
rankin/bass Frost these letters this is
chicory boom sing
don't go away Christmas I want to stay
in this room